Et voilà!
-Ah trop bien
-T'es une vraie sirène
-Tu me prends en photo
Ouais!
C'est trop drôle
Ah, t'es trop belle
Oh attend le coucher de soleil il est magnifique
Je vais faire un selfie
-Quoi? Zoé, ZOÉ REVIENT ZOÉ JE VEUX FAIRE UNE PHOTO MOI AUSSI
C'EST, JE VOIS RIEN PUTAIN
C'ÉTAIT MON IDÉE DE VENIR ICI
DETERRE MOI !
Ça va chérie, qu'est-t'a?
Bah tu sais y'a une maison d'édition qui m'a contacté pour écrire un livre
-Paraît que ça cartonne
-Bravo, j'suis trop contente pour toi
Et t'en est où là?
Pour l'instant j'ai que le heu...
Le prix
[Ensemble] 15 Euros..
-Pas mal hein?
-Pas mal.. 19 Euros
-Ah ouais c'est p'être mieux
-Ouais, y'a du cash
Faut que je recommence tout
Voilà
*Musique*
Cet endroit est bien
C'est quoi ça?  Tu nous as fais se déplacer pour ça?
Non mais je ne comprend pas. Sur l'instagram du resto, je te jure c'était hyper beau
Mais c'est dégueulasse ce truc là, je le prend pas en photo, c'est mort hein. Regarde la gueule du truc
-Pourquoi on a pas ça nous?
-J'en sais rien moi
[Musique dramatique]
Hey c'est pas
Euuhhh
Kylie Jenner là-bas?
En petit, regardez-là. Oui c'est elle, Kylie Jenner, l'influenceuse
-C'est Kylie Jenner!
-Oui, si on plisse les yeux!
-Ah mais oui!
-Elle vient pas souvent hein dans le coin!
-Oui, il me semble qu'elle a un petit pied à terre par ici
Ah non non, c'est un chevreuil en faite
[Chuchotant] Tu l'as?
-Oui, et toi tu l'as?
Hoo elle est belle la tienne
Super, Bravo!
-Bon appétit!
-À toi aussi!
*Musique*
Alice?
-Oh non
-Bas écoute il y avait plus que ça d'accord? Ils se sont faites dévalisé toutes
-Les bouée flamants roses
-Héé moi c'est mort hein
Je ne me prend pas en photo avec une bouée pneu hein
-Mon instagram c'est pas un camping
-Ok, laisse moi 2 s'condes
*Musique*
Bon, avec un #DIY... euh…#Récup #Ecolo...
Bah ça peut le faire !
-Allez, monte dessus je te prends en photo.
-Non, non
*Musique*
ZOE !
JE TE JURE ALICE JE SAIS PAS CE QU'IL S'EST PASSÉ D'ACCORD ?
-POURQUOI TOI ET PAS MOI ?
-Je sais pas, il y'a du avoir un bug écoute !
TU LE SAIS QUE C'EST MON RÊVE D'ETRE CERTIFIÉE SUR INTAGRAM !
COMMENT TU L'AS EUE LA PETITE PASTILLE BLEUE ?
-T'AS PAYÉ ?
-MAIS BIEN SÛR QUE NON J'AI PAS PAYÉ, J-J'AI RIEN FAIT, JE-JE TE DIT QUE JE SAIS PAS !
-ET PUIS TU PEUX PAS ÊTRE TOUT SIMPLEMENT HEUREUSE POUR MOI ?
-JE SUIS HEUREUSE POUR TOI !
Eh bah souris alors !
J-Je souris !
Tu pleures Alice !
NON !
ME TOUCHE PAS !
Je te déteste...
*Musique*
Et c'est pour ça, qu'il est hyper important les loulous, d'avoir tojours avec vous...
...votre gourde, car elle vous permet de diminuer votre consommation de plastique et donc...
MAIS ZOE, QU'EST-CE TU FOUS LA, ON VA LOUPER NOTRE VOL !
-Bah j'ai pas vu l'heure passer
-Bah oui, bah Dubaï il attends pas, y'a l'escale Istanbul j'te rappelle ! C'est moins cher, ALLEZ VITE !
-A Istanbul ?
-Bah oui !
-Et on pourra faire du 4x4 ?
-Mais oui, on pourra faire du 4x4 !
-ALLEZ VIENS !
Oh putain, y'a ma gourde !
-ON S'EN BAT LES COUILLES DE TA GOURDE DE MERDE !
-ET DU BUGGY, ON POURRA FAIRE DU BUGGY ?
-On fera du buggy !
*Musique*
Depuis ce matin t'es tombée enceinte ? Ouais bien sûr...
Oh purée, t'as fait ça pour gagner des likes...
Ca marche du tonnerre, depuis mon annonce, j'ai des abonnés, des likes, j'te raconte même pas !
D'accord, et tu vas leur dire quoi quand tu vas devoir accoucher ?
Mais j'ai pensé à tout !
-Nan mais enfin regardes son visage, ça s'voit qu'c'est en plastoc là…
-Mais j'ai pas terminé !
*photo*
Mais bien sûr ! L'emoji pour préserver l'anonymat du bébé !
-Ca c'est malin ça !
-Attends, c'est pas quand le bébé est moche qu'on met un emoji sur son visage ?
-Et oui, t'as p'têtre raison oui !
-Eh oui...
*Musique*
Et voilà, ça y'est chérie, je me suis fait tatouer !
Quoi ?
Ch'ui trop contente ! C'est pour mon amour de la nature, c'est pour aussi, celui des océeans !
Ma démarche écologique et tout...
-Tu l'as trouvé sur Google image non ?
-Ouais !
-C'est le logo Shell, des pompes à essence...
Mais non !
T'as tapé coquillage ? Coquillage, c'est Shell en anglais...
-On y va ?
-Retire le moi Alice !
-Non !
*Musique*
-Hop !
-Tu vois le livre là ?
-Comme...ça !
-Super belle photo !
-C'est vrai ?
-Très bien, tiens !
-Oh merci beaucoup ma chérie !
-Tu peux me prendre en photo aussi ?
-Ouais bien sûr !
-Bah non !
-Bah quoi ?
-Bah non, écoutes !
-Moi aussi, j'ai le droit de faire une photo avec un livre !
Ok, d'accord, mais pas ce livre, pourquoi t'as choisi ça ?
Bah ch'ais pas moi, j'vais dans une llibrairie, j'prends un gros livre euh...
Bon, ouvre le, on va prendre une photo de toi qui le lit à l'intérieur
Comme ça ?
Euh, nan attends, on voit le mot islamiste là…
Islamiste...ah oui, merde...
*Musique*
-Tu vois les jambes là ?
-Ouais
-Et bah c'est pas des jambes, c'est des Knackis
-Mais nan !
Eh si !
C'est pour ça, j't'ai demandé d'en acheter, comme j'ai pas les jambes épilées...
...comme ça paf, je mets les knackis et ça fait une belle photo !
J'ai pris ça moi...
...des knackis ball...
...eh oui
-Tu peux p'têt' essayer ?
-MAIS NON, ON VA PAS ESSAYER, CA VA M'FAIRE DES MOIGNONS !
LES GENS ILS VEULENT PAS VOIR UN MOIGNON !
Ouais mais bon, tu préfères des jambes velues, ou des moignons comme ça parfaitements épilés ?
-Bah on essaye !
-Bah oui on essaye !
Allez..
-Oula non, c'est raté.
-Nan ça tient pas la route, ah j'aime pas du tout.
-C'est terrible
*Musique*
-Tiens ma chérie !
-Nan mais c'est pas mon anniversaire !
-Mais non mais je sais !
-C'est pur fêter ton compte Insta certifié !
-C'est vrai ? Mais j'croyais que tu m'en voulait de l'avoir et pas toi !
Mais n'importe quoi !
-Moi je suis heureuse pour toi, tu rigoles ! Vas-y j'te prends en photo !
-Bah je souffle là alors ?
-Nan nan fais semblant !
-D'accord.
-Voilà plus proche !
-Approche toi !
-Comme ça là ?
-Ouais là c'est très bien !
-C'est bon
-Ca brûle là non ?
-Non !
-BAH SI ! BAH SI CA BRÛLE !
JE BRÛLE ALICE !
-JE BRÛLE !
-C'est la vie !
*Musique*